Okay.
Apologies in advance for people who are sick
of this topic, but I just, we're really struggling
with this and I just am, I recognize that
I'm venting to you.
I'm just communicating to you what's going
on behind the scenes at the show.
Uh, we have been talking off and on for years
about issues of demonetization on Youtube.
I won't bore you by rehashing the entire thing,
but I'll just talk about this week's events
this week.
As soon as the shootings happened over the
weekend.
I knew I've got to cover this stuff and we're
not gonna make any money off of it.
It's going to be a week of talking about the
shootings themselves, responses to the shootings
from elected officials, gun control issues
that will relate to that.
What does Trump say?
What do Republicans say violence in video
games have being related to shootings, Fox
News, repeating the shooter's manifesto.
There's all of these direct and secondary
stories related to the shootings which are
important and must be covered.
I mean, I would be doing a disservice to you
if I didn't cover these stories on Tuesday
because of youtube rules about sensitive content
not being brand safe.
That's literally the term they use.
Half of the videos that we published on Tuesday
were demonetized and yesterday it got even
worse.
Two thirds of the videos we published yesterday,
Wednesday were demonetized.
So I understand the policy, right?
The policy.
When you look at it makes very clear that
there are a number of different elements that
preclude monetization on youtube and we know
this going in and it's not even that youtube
hasn't been clear about it.
When you look at what that list is, you very
quickly understand that on the basis of a
anything related to controversial issues and
sensitive events, that's not going to be monetized.
Firearms related content that's not going
to be monetized, harmful or dangerous acts,
violence.
I mean all of these things are inherent to
just talking about the real world violence
that took place over the weekend in Texas
and Ohio, but this is a problem because I'm
not alleging that it's censorship.
I'm not alleging that it's illegal.
Youtube is obviously a completely within their
rights to do this, but it does have an agenda
setting effect.
Many channels consider these numbers 560,000
views this week of hours covering these issues
were demonetized.
Most youtube channels don't even get 560,000
views in a month.
Okay?
In fact, most youtube channels don't get 560,000
views.
In a year.
Uh, if you look just account people who have
an account and have uploaded a couple of cat
videos or whatever, uh, that is the number
of views that we had.
Demonetized just this week just related to
coverage of the shootings and this has an
agenda setting power.
We've got a disconnect funding for programs
like ours from the whims of advertisers.
And I'll very briefly mention it just indulged
me.
Two ways to do that with us.
You become a member on our website@wwwdotjoinpacman.com
it's very cheap.
You get great perks including a daily members
only show and or make a pledge on Patrion
at patrion.com/david Pakman show where we
are rapidly approaching 2000 patrons and you
can contribute as little as a dollar a month.